what was the last thing that you guys
talked about in the instinct
group chat it's all about babies the
nsync group chat has two new babies to
discuss
what do they know lance bass announced
that he and husband michael turchin
are expecting twins via surrogate a baby
girl
and a baby boy the couple have been
married since 2014.
their happy news follows many previous
ivf attempts
just last fall one of their surrogates
had been eight weeks pregnant with a
baby boy
then tragically lost a pregnancy to
miscarriage
i can't help but kind of feel for you
and michael in the journey that you guys
have gone on and you've been very vocal
about what's happened
i know you lost the surrogate earlier
this year
so so how are you guys doing uh
with everything involving that yeah
you know we're still staying positive uh
you know we know that this process
can be long we have several friends that
have gone through ivf
and um you know it's it's it's not as
perfect as everyone you know it's like
you think oh it'll happen the first time
it hardly ever you know works the first
time so we knew that going in and we're
just trying to stay positive we're now
going on
three years with this but it looks like
things are
gonna be great um you know we we have a
surrogate now we have our donor so
hopefully uh soon we'll be able to uh
celebrate now the 42 year old singer is
opening up about what it means to be
expecting kids with his partner
lance says we knew that we wanted to be
very open and transparent with our
experience
because we wanted gay couples to be able
to relate to us
adding that he wants to tell those
couples if you want to start that family
start that family it's going to be
incredible
the twins are due this november but
lance says he's hoping for halloween
babies
there it is again there's something in
this house
i most certainly feel a presence here
more than one
ant helped put his dream out into the
universe he and michael filmed an
elaborate fake horror movie trailer for
tick-tock
michael look
lance opened up to e.t in 2018 about
starting their parenthood journey what
is the
the real story and where you guys are at
with that because i know you'd be
amazing
uh no it's something we're very excited
about i mean the reason i wanted to get
married to this guy is
i know he'll be an amazing dad um and
we've been putting off for a long time
but uh
this is the year that we're actually
starting the process
and um and actually yeah i mean as just
last week
um really started the process so uh
we're excited we've met with surrogates
we're looking at eggs and
we now have the person representing us
and contracts are being made and
i mean it's such a process we had no
idea existed
but it's also fascinating too it's it's
already amazing
you